beyonce shares some rare sweet snaps
from a recent outing with her kids
is this the biggest thing you've ever
done becoming a mom this is my
greatest greatest accomplishment and
i am the happiest i've ever been and i
feel the most empowered
it just makes me feel so lucky to be a
woman
the grammy-winning singer first shared a
selfie with her oldest daughter
nine-year-old blue ivy before a few pics
from what appears to be
a lunch at nobu in malibu that's
three-year-old rumi in a colorful dress
walking barefoot towards the water and
that's the mom of three reaching for
roomies twin brother sir
as they approach the shore i'm very
happy
queen bee rarely shares pics of her kids
especially her twins
but she did recently share these images
of blue
after her big grammy win yeah
you heard me right her grammy win
the best thing in the world
[Music]
singing beyonce and jay-z's
nine-year-old daughter
celebrated winning grammy gold for best
music video for brown skin
[Music]
else girl not only is she featured on
the track
and stars in the music video alongside
her famous mama
she also wrote a verse for the song
this makes me proud that's blue
celebrating sporting a crown
looking like a boss holding the trophy
sideways so she can drink out of it with
a straw
and that's blue holding her grammy gold
smiling ear to ear
of course it's no secret that blue is
one talented kiddo
[Music]
back in january beyonce's mom and blue's
grandma tina knowles lawson
took to instagram to share the cutest
clip of her granddaughter at dance class
and well she's a better dancer than all
of us
[Music]
blue's talent expands beyond music and
movement too
she's quite a makeup artist tina shared
this selfie on instagram in october
rocking skeleton makeup courtesy of blue
i bought blue so many makeup kits uh
much to her her dad's dismay but
um yeah because you know dads don't like
that but uh
it's just for playtime okay we have fun
she's amazing
what is like her specialty eyes oh my
gosh
she puts stones and does all this fancy
stuff she can do a
perfect cat eye and in november she
added
narrator to her resume lending her voice
to the children's book
hair love by matthew a cherry and when
my hair is in two
puffs i'm above the clouds like a
superhero
my hair even does magic tricks
you